esperábamos lo que conocimos este largo
reporte que todo el mundo estaba
esperando se publicara y se publica
precisamente días antes de que los
republicanos tomen control de la cámara
de representantes pero conocimos
precisamente que en el año 2020 cuando
Trump era presidente ni su esposa ni él
pagaron impuestos federales tampoco lo
hicieron o de una manera muy reducida
durante el 2000 del 2015 al 2020 cuando
precisamente se hace esta auditoría los
el expresidente reportó no recibir
ingresos o recibir ingresos muy bajos y
precisamente Esto llevó a que pagara muy
pocos impuestos también se conoció que
la la administración y la agencia de
impuestos de Estados Unidos pues no hizo
la adecuada auditoría Durante los
últimos tres años de administración de
Donald Trump y ahí pueden haber también
pues futuras disputas legales al
respecto el expresidente ya reaccionó en
sus redes sociales dijo que esto era una
cacería de brujas que desde el día uno
empezó su campaña lo han tratado de pues
hacer esta cacería de brujas y que era
una lástima para el país